the raiders less than a week away from
their first home opener in allegiance
stadium with fans and there's some good
news for some of you ticket prices
dropping madison kimbrough joining us
live from the legion with much more
madison
many fans are excited about this and
hope that prices go down even more as we
get an approach home games closer on
here at allegiant stadium and the reason
behind the price drop is what everyone
seems to really be focused on
they went from over 2000 to 500 because
of the mandatory vaccination so now
they're cutting their audience down
raiders fans seeing a drop in home game
ticket pricing while still pricey for
most the drop is noticeable i'm happy
about it because at the current price i
just can't afford to go to a game i'd
love to one of the biggest reasons for
this many believe is the vaccination
mandate put in place by the raiders nfl
organization the seats plummeted
plummeted when the raiders announced
that they're requiring vaccinations to
get into the stadium first team in the
nfl to do so requiring proof of
vaccination for all home games at
allegiant stadium and this idea sits
well for some but not for all i'm
vaccinated so it doesn't bother me
and i'm happy to you know i'm going to
concerts in town where the extra
vaccination proof i don't mind that i
will never attend a raiders game
as
if they require that
120 thousand dollars down the drain or
i'll try to sell the tickets even to
break even
now raiders allowed season ticket
holders to either roll over season
tickets to next year or even get a
refund as for the season opener that
kicks off this upcoming monday september
13th that's going to be against the
baltimore ravens we are all very excited
about that reporting live from allegiant
stadium madison kimbrough 8 news now